[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
[Music]
it's
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i think
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nevermind
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
positions
[Music]
special
do
now
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
accompanied by medal of honor recipient
sergeant major
thomas p payne united states army
[Music]
[Music]
i invite you to join me in prayer
almighty god on this day of national
remembrance we pray as the psalmist of
old
deliver us o lord from evil men who plot
evil things in their heart
maintain the cause of the afflicted and
execute justice
for the needy today we thank you for the
valorous
attributes and actions of sergeant major
patrick payne
that indeed delivered the oppressed you
are the one who placed him in a family
of love
in a nation he loves fostering the pure
motivation of all warriors
fight for those who stand behind him you
equipped his hands for warfare
and forged within him a heart that
regarded the liberty of
others of greater value than his own
safety
you assigned him in the ranks of those
whose common bond is
uncommon valor when terror needed to be
boldly confronted
your work through him not only preserved
life
but preserved the legacy of his team and
the ideals of our great nation
nevertheless we know that opposing
evil comes with a great cause so we pray
that the honor of this ceremony
and the ministry of your spirit would
comfort the families
and the teammates of master sergeant
josh wheeler
and master sergeant john dunbar i pray
in jesus name
amen
thank you very much chaplain went in
really
beautiful job and thank you for your
service
please thank you
today it's my privilege to present the
congressional
medal of honor to a warrior who has
devoted the last two decades to
fighting the forces of terror
please join me in welcoming today's
extraordinary recipient
sergeant major thomas patrick payne
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
so
thank you very much we're grateful to be
joined by
pat's really wonderful wife allison
and allison thank you very much for
being here on this very momentous
occasion this is
this is the big one you know that this
is the big one
also with us is patrick and allison's
six-year-old son
aaron aaron thank you for being here he
got a very nice
little award back there a beautiful pen
right
you're going to save that pen thank you
aaron i want you to know that
uh your dad is one of the bravest
men anywhere in the world you know that
right you knew that before i think you
knew that before we knew it
so congratulations to both
with us also is our first lady thank you
darling
and vice president mike pence mike thank
you very much along with
secretary of defense mark esper mark
thank you
congressman richard hudson richard
richard thank you very much secretary of
the army ryan mccarthy
thanks ryan chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff
mark milley mark thank you very much
it's amazing the way all these big
generals are showing up this is
something huh
this is the big one as i say always do
it's always will be
the army chief of staff james pecanville
james thank you thank you very much
james and sergeant major of the army
michael grinston thank you mike thank
you very much
i also want to recognize the three medal
of honor recipients that are
with us matthew williams
edward byers and walter
marm thank you very much
[Applause]
that's great a lot of brave people are
with us today
pat grew up in a small town in south
carolina
his dad is a police officer his
grandfather
served in world war ii in korea vietnam
service to our country really goes
through their veins very very rapidly
exactly 19 years ago today on september
11
2001 news of the attack in our nation's
great great country this was just an
attack like
has never happened to us but it went
through pat's high school and
went through his classroom and pat was
sitting there listening
his teacher solemnly told the students
that their
generation had a fight to win they were
going to fight
and fight to win in that moment pat was
called to action
he knew that his country needed him ten
short months later at the age of 18 pat
was
in army basic training at fort benning
suny joined the elite ranks of the
legendary
army rangers pat became an exceptional
soldier
and expert sniper he saw heavy combat in
multiple
theaters of battle in 2010
during a deployment in afghanistan his
leg was severely wounded by an enemy
grenade
while recovering in south carolina pat
met with his wife alice said well that
was probably not a bad wound then was it
huh it was worth
i hope you're gonna say it was worth it
it was
less than two years after being injured
pat competed against some of america's
toughest warriors
and won the prestigious best ranger
competition
among the most grueling physical
contests anywhere in the country
in october of 2015
on his 14th deployment pat was part of a
team
assigned to plan and conduct an
operation to rescue over 70 kurdish
prisoners
being held by isis barbarians in iraq
the team soon received horrifying
intelligence that the terrorists were
planning to massacre their captives and
buried them in freshly dug graves
patted his teammates raced into action
after midnight on october 22nd
pat boarded a helicopter and departed on
a mission
to free the hostages from two buildings
guarded by
dozens of ruthless and bloodthirsty isis
terrorists
he was in command of a team clearing one
of the
compounds as soon as the ramp to his
helicopter went down
pat rushed into a blistering hail of
gunfire
pat and his team swiftly overpowered the
enemy
secured the building and freed 38 of the
hostages
then pat received word that the rest of
the assault team
was facing harsh resistance in another
complex
pat turned to one of his fellow soldiers
and said
let's get into the fight right now let's
get into the fight
he saw that the other building was on
fire and he knew
more of the hostages were still trapped
inside
he and his team climbed up ladders to
the roof and opened up fire in the enemy
multiple isis fighters detonated suicide
vests ripping a portion of the building
into pieces
but pat and his fellow rangers fought
through the fire
the bullets and the deadly blasts pat
navigated to the
impacted all around him pat succeeded in
cutting one of the locks
before scorching sweltering heat forced
him to
leave the building for some air pat
caught his breath in a few seconds and
was back
he ran right back into that raging blaze
he sliced the final lock and released
the rest of the hostages
as the building began to collapse he
received orders to evacuate
but he refused to do so he didn't want
to leave anyone behind
pat ran back into the burning building
that was collapsing
two more times he saved multiple
hostages and he was
the last man to leave he wouldn't leave
no matter what they said no matter who
ordered him to do it he wouldn't do it
he was the last one out
it was one of the largest and most
daring rescue missions in american
history
patted his team rescued 75 captives
and killed 20 isis terrorists pat you
embody the righteous glory
of american valor we stand in all of
your heroic daring and gallant deeds
you truly went above and beyond the call
of duty to earn our nation's
highest military honor pat would be the
first to remind us
that he was not alone that day in the
battle one army ranger made the ultimate
sacrifice
master sergeant josh wheeler
josh was something right bet josh was
something you've thought you've said
that before
today we're deeply moved to be joined by
master sergeant willer's wife
ashley wheeler ashley our hearts break
for your loss
a great man that was a great man
ashley where is ashley ashley please
stand up
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you ashley
our nation endures because fearless
warriors like
josh willing to lay down their lives for
our freedom
our children can grow up in peace
because josh had the courage to
face down evil our debt to him and to
you
is everlasting and again thank you very
much ashley we appreciate it very much
we will honor him forever you know that
very special group of
warriors men great men
patter said that as soon as our soldiers
boots hit the ground
they are ambassadors of the american way
of life
everywhere they go the men and women of
our armed forces
and still are friends with hope our
enemies with dread in our fellow
citizens with unyielding american pride
over the course of his service pat has
embarked on an astounding really an
astounding
17 deployments in defense of our nation
general milly that's a lot right is that
a lot
that's a lot okay i needed that little
extra confirmation
that's a lot he now serves as an
instructor at the u.s army special
operations command training the next
generation of american warriors
today he joins the immortal company of
our most revered
american heroes pat you personify
the motto rangers lead the way and you
inspire us all
it is now my privilege to present
sergeant major
thomas patrick payne with the
congressional
medal of honor i'd like to ask the
military aide to come forward and read
the citation thank you very much
attention to orders the medal of honor
is awarded to sergeant first class
thomas p
payne united states army for conspicuous
gallantry and intrepidity
at the risk of his life above and beyond
the call of duty on october 22nd
2015. his heroism and selfless actions
were key to liberating
75 hostages during a contested rescue
mission
that resulted in 20 enemies killed in
action
sergeant first class payne's gallantry
under fire and uncommon valor are in
keeping with the highest traditions of
military service
and reflect great credit upon himself
the united states special operations
command
in the united states army
[Applause]
so
i invite you to join me in prayer
gracious god thank you for the gift of
liberty that you have given us
and for those who have safeguarded
liberty through heroic
acts for our sake and for the sake of
others
your call upon each of our lives may not
be to serve as first responders
or warriors on the field of battle
rushing into burning buildings
rescuing others even still
may our participation here today and the
strengthening of your spirit
compel us all to live lives of honor and
valor
for the good of your kingdom for the
good of our own families
and for the good of the united states of
america
i pray in jesus name amen
you
[Applause]
[Music]
this okay